- [Instructor] We have
already introduced ourselves
to the idea of price
discrimination in other videos,
and in this video, we're
gonna try to classify
the different ways that
a firm might engage
in price discrimination.
So first of all, just as
a review of what it is,
this is when a firm
charges different prices
to different consumers in order to capture
as much of the consumer
surplus as possible.
In other videos, we visualize that
by showing the consumer surplus
and showing how a firm might visually
try to eat into that consumer surplus.
But let's talk about the different types.
So the first type of price discrimination
is known as first degree.
First degree price discrimination,
often known as perfect
price discrimination,
and this is really the most theoretical
of all the ones we're gonna talk about.
In first degree, or perfect
price discrimination,
the firm is able to essentially capture
the entire consumer surplus
by charging each individual
exactly what they are willing to pay.
Now, in order to pull this off,
you would have to
magically be able to know
what someone is willing to pay.
When they show up, you say
oh, I'm gonna charge you $5
'cause you can read their mind
that they're willing to pay exactly $5,
and the next person to walk in,
you say I'm gonna charge you $4
'cause you know that's exactly
what they're willing to pay.
Now in the real world, we
can't get to that level
of precision, but firms
can try to get there.
Now, a general principle that's
true, that needs to be true
to do first degree price discrimination,
or really any type of
price discrimination,
is the different users
shouldn't be able to know
what the other person is getting it for
and they shouldn't be able
to trade between them.
So there's one principle
when we're talking about
price discrimination where
there is no arbitrage.
Arbitrage.
Arbitrage is just a fancy word for
if I know something is, I
can buy it for $5 over here
and if I can sell it for $7 over here,
well then it would be very natural
for someone to buy it for
five and sell for seven.
And so if someone, if there were a firm
that were out there doing first
degree price discrimination,
but if people knew about it,
well then, they could
say hey, you over there,
you're willing to pay five
and that's what the firm is charging you,
but I know a place,
'cause the firm's willing
to sell it to me for three,
so I'll buy it for three
and sell it to you for five.
So in order for price
discrimination in general to happen,
especially something like perfect
or first degree price discrimination,
you need to have no arbitrage.
Now the next type of price discrimination
is known as, and this is
no surprise, second degree.
Second degree price discrimination,
and this is a situation where a firm
is going to charge different
folks different prices
based on quantity that
they are going to buy.
And you might have seen this,
where you might have
things like bulk discounts.
Bulk discounts.
And so it's a way of
differentiating to some degree.
It's unlikely that that the firm
is able to capture the
entire consumer surplus,
but you could say hey, the big contractor
that needs to buy a lot of wood,
they might have a lower
willingness to pay,
so let's give them a lower
price based on volume,
while the hobbyist, who just need to buy
a little bit of wood, we can
charge them a higher price
based on their lower volume.
So here, you're talking
about price versus quantity.
And then you could go to,
and once again, no surprise,
third degree price discrimination.
And third degree price discrimination,
this is when you are
looking at characteristics
of the consumer.
So consumer, or I should say maybe buyer.
So this is based on buyer characteristics.
Characteristics.
So the classic example
of third degree price discrimination is
when you go to a museum, they
might have a different price
for seniors or for young
children versus for adults.
And the reason why they do that
is they might say, hey, seniors might have
a lower willingness to pay,
but we want them to come anyway.
They might do it for
other reasons as well,
just for good social
values, whatever else,
but it could also be,
it is, by definition,
a form of price discrimination.
You're giving a different
price to different people
based on who they are.
Now in the real world,
what firms try to do
is some combination of various types
of price discrimination
and they could also vary the
actual products a little bit
so that they aren't perfectly identical.